williams getting chris paul back into
this ball game you can rest tomorrow
let's finish these guys off george
against booker
offensive foul that elbow we've seen
this play a number of times in this
conference finals the defender gets up
into
to the offensive player and as he makes
his move the elbow
gives him a shot to the face now
remember booker has that broken nose
and he's not wearing the mask tonight
and is this a play you take a look at
wow well they're going to
that hurts even without a broken nose
and booker's shaking offensive foul
[Applause]
has had that earlier in the series in
the shot from patrick beverly and now
it's
paul george
this was game two and you see the
inadvertent headbutt beverly leaning in
to try and knock the ball away
he left the game for a while now some
stitches had to reset the nose
and interestingly chris paul is sitting
over by the clippers
next to reggie jackson i just can't
imagine how much that hurts
now chris paul gets off the
side boards comes back i'll tell you
what though mike the more we cover
teams the more you can fall in love with
different talent throughout this league
and devin booker is absolutely a
franchise home run talent
that has an edge and is cut from the
right clothes are you going to say
some replay has confirmed the on-floor
decision offensive file assess paul
george
just the offensive foul what you talked
about earlier he's got he's got this
toughness about him this competitive
streak
that has been really fun to watch and
classy too determined
competes respectful and his mentality
right now is
i can tell you i'm too close to let go
the road i'm trying to finish these guys
off
hurt or not hurt talks a lot about his
dad his dad
played briefly in the nba played in the
cbas that name is melvin
also played a lot overseas he said the
best advice from his dad
have a short memory a lot of players get
caught up on what just happened
he's old